science it's incredible we got talking
robots self-driving cars virtual reality
is becoming real oh and now the next big
step for Humanity and science the
amazing team of Microsoft engineer have
developed a program that will caption
any any image perfect let's show how it
works use this photo I think it's a
snow-covered mountain
how is that possible what is this I
don't even know what this is grill tent
have you seen terminator this is step
one how could we have been so blind how
could we have been so blind
we shouldn't have abused our power the
robots are here and there to [ __ ] with
it Arnold Schwarzenegger was right all
exercises that you do with your own
bodyweight are great
how could we have been so blank this is
the end of humanity this is the end
let's try another picture I am not
really confident but I think it's a red
white and green maybe there is hope for
Humanity after all what about this image
I am not really confident but I think
it's a couple of giraffes that are next
to a window now I don't know how
giraffes next to a window would look
like but I'm fairly certain this it's
not it do you think I don't see through
your lies this is a giraffe looking
through a window this is the giraffe
looking through a window now this is a
giraffe looking through a window they're
sisters shitty me what about DJ collie
can it recognise DJ Kalle I am 98% sure
that's DJ cat I knew it I think it's a
person on a surfboard in a skate park
now why the [ __ ] would you use the
surfboard and a skate park what about
this meme of check septic a it's spot on
again what about this vagina I think
it's a close-up of two giraffes near a
tree what is this obsession with your
ass
another one it's a group of people
standing next to a cow yeah yeah that's
that's a goat you [ __ ] idiot what
about me what about me I think it's a
girl holding a teddy bear and she seems
how [ __ ] dare you
I'm gonna tell tumblr about this I will
find the giraffes
and I will put them to justice
including whoever is responsible for
this caption vine
I'm watching you all right bridge thank
you so much for watching another video
if you enjoyed thank you for leaving a
like I really appreciate it
post on my facebook some of the results
that you got from cap and pot and as
always thank you both so much for
watching stay awesome brush the fence in
two dead people I saw this post on
tumblr and I just want to say this is
extremely offensive not only to me but
to the people of the universe today it
is triggered hurt and vulnerable